direction le loir et cher à présent s le
coup de grâce pour ces clôtures de plus
en plus nombreuses qui balafre la
sologne
c'est ce que veut croire le député du
cher françois cormier bullygeois l'élu
doit présenter cette année une
proposition de loi pour interdire
l'achat son enclos derrière lui des
associations locales et des chasseurs
qui dénonce depuis des années un
désastre pour la grande faune sauvage
laurent clavel entre deux propriétés ou
sur le bord des routes en sologne du
grillage à perte de vue
cinq mille kilomètres au total soit deux
fois la distance entre paris et moscou
derrière ces clôtures des parties de
chasse entre riches propriétaires du
genre gros gibier patrons du cac 40 et
grandes fortunes françaises
des parties de chasse qualifiée de
carnage par le député du cher françois
cormier bullygeois qui veut y mettre fin
avec sa proposition de loi si ma
proposition de loi passe et qui consiste
à dire que le droit de chasse est
interdite dans les propriétés en close
alors c'était grands propriétaires
auront le choix entre deux possibilités
soit faire tomber des clôtures et à ce
moment là ils pourront reprendre la
chasse soit ils conserveront leur
affreuse clôture mais ils n'auront plus
le droit de chasser car derrière cette
interdiction de la chasse son enclos
c'est bien l'engagement qui est dans le
viseur de l'élu et il faut frapper fort
les propriétaires sentant le vent
tourner et on multipliait les clôtures
ces dernières années pour les
associations cette proposition de loi
est cruciale pour la survie de la
sologne
comme ce sans oublier la grande faune
sauvage ne circulent plus librement
la sologne normalement la sologne c'est
une seule ligne ouverte où tous vie
librement les jours on chasse moi je
pratique la chasse traditionnelle on
prélève un ou deux à niveau dans la
journée on est on est content on tire on
tire pas les animaux peuvent se au moins
ils peuvent s'échapper là dedans il peut
pas s'échapper du tout là dedans folie
de s'imaginer dans des enclos comme ça
ils vont jusqu'à faire 350 360 sanglier
par jour c'est vraiment du ball-trap
cetc chasser dans la zone après plus de
vingt ans de combat
la proposition de loi du député cormier
bullygeois est un espoir pour ces
solognot elle devrait être présentée
devant l'assemblée nationale dans le
courant de l'année